TWO DAYS FROM NOW.
HARRIS.
>> Harris: THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE "NEW YORK POST" COVER TODAY
TIDAL WAVE ALARM.
CITIES IN EVERY STATE GETTING
READY FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO ALLOW THOUSANDS OF MOSTLY
UNVETTED PEOPLE TO FAN OUT
ACROSS AMERICA.
A NEW OP-ED KEYING IN ON THE
CHAOS IN EL PASO.
HERE IS A LOOK AT THE VIDEO.
WE SHOWED YOU THAT OVERRUN
FACILITY.
THE HEADLINE SAYS THE CITY'S
MIGRANT STATE OF EMERGENCY IS A
TASTE OF WHAT NATION FACES AS
BIDEN SHRUGS AT BORDER CRISIS.
HE SHRUGS AT THIS.
SHERIFF MARC DANIELS OF COCHISE
COUNTY, ARIZONA AND A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE TEXAS
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY.
LET'S START IN COCHISE COUNTY
WHERE THE DRUGS ARE FLOWING IN
SUCH A MANNER, SHERIFF, IT GETS
LESS TALK ABOUT IN TERMS OF OUR
COVERAGE RIGHT NOW BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE AS MANY PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS BUT FENTANYL, OH MY
GOODNESS, LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
>> GOOD MORNING.
LET ME JUST SAY HOURS AGO I WAS
ON A SCENE WHERE THERE WAS
DEATH, FENTANYL, SMUGGLING,
ASSAULT ON MY DEPUTIES.
JUST SEVERAL HOURS AGO.
SMUGGLING FROM THE BORDER INTO
OUR COMMUNITIES AND TALKING TO
MY DEPUTY THAT WAS TRYING TO
SAVE A GUY'S LIFE WHEN A CAR
CAME BY AND HIT THAT SMUGGLER
AND KILLED HIM.
AGAIN, THIS GOES ON EVERY DAY IN
COCHISE COUNTY.
WE DEAL WITH SMUGGLING, HUMAN,
DRUGS, YOU NAME IT, WE'RE SEEING
IT.
WHAT WE DON'T SEE IS
PRIORITIZATION FROM PRESIDENT
BIDEN AND CONGRESS.
ALL I HEAR IS THE BLAME GAME.
AND THE ACKNOWLEDGEMENT WE HAVE
A PROBLEM AT THE BORDER.
WE HAVE A PROBLEM ON THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER.
>> Harris: WE DO.
1,933 MILES OF IT AND WE ARE
LOOKING NOW AT TEXAS, THE
BACKGROUND VIDEO THAT YOU SEE
THERE PULLING INTO FOCUS IS FROM
OUR EXCLUSIVE LOOK WE GOT WHEN I
WAS WITH THE LIEUTENANT IN THE
DEL RIO, TEXAS, JUST A SHORT FEW
WEEKS AGO AS THE FISCAL YEAR WAS
ENDING.
LIEUTENANT, FIRST OF ALL, HOW
MUCH WORSE HAS IT GOTTEN SINCE
YOU AND I DID THE NIGHTTIME RIDE
ALONG AND SAW SO MANY PEOPLE
TRYING TO GET IN?
>> YOU SAW FIRSTHAND WHEN YOU
WERE OUT THERE WITH US SAW NOT
JUST THE WORK THE TROOPERS DOING
ON PRIVATE RANCHS TRYING TO
CIRCUMVENT CHECKPOINTS BUT THE
HUMAN SMUGGLER.
THEY SMUGGLED ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
INTO OUR COUNTRY.
SINCE THEN THERE HAS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN HUMAN
SMUGGLING AT THE DEL RIO SECTOR
AND WHAT THE SHERIFF MENTIONED
AS FAR AS DRUGS.
ONE THING THAT'S VERY CONCERNING
TO US AS A STATE IS THE FACT
WHEN TITLE 42 IS LIFTED WE'LL
SEE A MASS FLOW OF MIGRATION
WE'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE IN
YEARS.
HISTORIC.
WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW IS
HISTORIC BUT IT IS HARD TO THINK
HOW MUCH WORSE CAN IT GET.
IT WILL BE A HURRICANE OF MASS
AND ILLEGAL MIGRATION TAKING
PLACE.
WHEN THAT TAKE PLACE THE CARTELS
USE IT TO THEIR ADVANTAGE.
ALL THE FOCUS WILL BE ON THE
MASS GROUPS COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER AND LEAVE MILES AND MILES
AND BORDERS UNPAT ROLLED.
THAT'S WHAT IS THE CONCERN FOR
DRUGS AND HUMAN SMUGGLING THAT
WILL TAKE PLACE.
>> Harris: I WANT TO BRING BACK
THE SHERIFF.
YOU COULD TALK TO EACH OTHER
ABOUT THIS.
YOU BROUGHT UP THE NEXT POINT
FOR ME, LIEUTENANT, WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN EVERYBODY IS CONCENTRATED
ON WHERE THE PEOPLE ARE TRYING
TO CROSS ILLEGALLY AND COMING IN
A WAVE TO NOGALES, FOR INSTANCE.
THE DRUGS HAVE REACHED EPIC
PROPORTIONS.
LET ME ASK THE SHERIFF HOW DO
YOU DEAL WITH THIS?
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
THE FISCAL YEAR JUST ENDED AND
NEARLY 1 MILLION POUNDS -- 22
POUNDS OF FENTANYL POWDER FROM
SMUGGLERS WERE JUST TAKEN.
CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION
SEIZED MORE THAN 14,000 POUNDS
OF FENTANYL IN ALL OF FISCAL
YEAR 2022.
THAT'S UP BY 10,000.
HOW CAN YOU HANDLE THAT,
SHERIFF?
>> WELL, IT'S HOW CAN AMERICA
HANDLE THAT, HARRIS?
THE FACT THAT WE CONTINUE TO SEE
A SLIPPERY SLOPE IN OUR COUNTRY
AS A RESULT OF THE SOUTHWEST
BORDER NOT BEING PRIORITIZED BY
THIS ADMINISTRATION AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
WHAT I KEEP HEARING IS WE DON'T
HAVE A PROBLEM, NUMBER ONE FROM
THE ADMINISTRATION.
THAT'S A FALSE NARRATIVE.
NUMBER TWO, AS LONG AS WE KEEP
IGNORING IT WILL WILL ONLY GET
WORSE IN AMERICA.
WE HAVE TO PRIORITIZE THE
BORDER.
OUR OATH OF OFFICE, WE NEED TO
PROTECT THIS COUNTRY.
WE AREN'T DOING IT.
WE HAVE TO WORK TOGETHER AND
UNTIL WE DO THAT AND RECOGNIZE
THE PROBLEM IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
WHERE WASHINGTON SAYS WE HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING BETTER, ACKNOWLEDGE
IT, WE CAN DO IT BETTER AND FIX
THE PROBLEM.
RIGHT NOW I DON'T SEE ANY HOPE
RIGHT NOW.
>> Harris: THIS IS MY FIRST
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK WITH YOU
SINCE WHAT WE SAW LAST WEEK.
AMERICAN POLICE OFFICERS NOW
TRYING TO HANDLE CRIME
SITUATIONS, FENTANYL IS SO
PERVASIVE IT IS EVERYWHERE AND
WE SAW AN OFFICER TREATED THREE
TIMES WITH A DRUG TO PREVENT HER
DEATH BY COMING INTO CONTACT
WITH SOMEBODY WHO HAD FENTANYL
ON THEM.
WHAT ARE THE DANGERS NOW TO
PROTECT THE RESIDENTS OF
AMERICA?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT.
HARRIS, THERE IS A PROBLEM.
WHEN YOU LOSE 300 AMERICANS A
DAY FOR A DRUG OVERDOSE,
POISONING AND WE AREN'T EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT.
AND JUST -- IN MY 38 YEARS I'VE
BEEN DOING THIS I CAN'T IMAGINE
OUR ELECTED LEADERS NATIONALLY
ARE NOT SAYING LET'S COME
TOGETHER AND LET'S ENGAGE WITH
SHIVERS, MAYORS, GOVERNORS,
TROOPERS AND LET'S FIX THE
PROBLEM.
WE CAN FIX IT IF WE WORK
TOGETHER.
UNTIL WE DO THAT I'M VERY
WORRIED.
>> Harris: I PRAY FOR OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND BORDER PATROL
AND WHAT THEY ARE DOING IN TEXAS
AND ARIZONA EVERY DAY.
THE ACTION THAT'S BEING TAKEN,
THOUGH, ISN'T ENOUGH FOR BORDER
PATROL.
I WANT TO GO BACK TO THE
LIEUTENANT.
YOU INTRODUCED ME TO SO MANY OF
OUR GREAT MEN AND WOMEN, TEXAS
DPS AND BORDER PATROL IN YOUR
STATE.
WHEN I READ ABOUT THE SUICIDES
THAT ARE HAPPENING BECAUSE THERE
IS SO MUCH -- THEY ARE
OVERWHELMED.
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE ON THE
GROUND, LIEUTENANT?
>> YOU KNOW, HARRIS, WE TRY TO
PROVIDE AS MUCH SUPPORT AS WE
CAN AS BORDER PATROL.
I TRY TO BE OUT THERE AS MUCH AS
I CAN EVERY DAY WORKING
ALONGSIDE THEM.
TRYING TO CAPTURE THE WORK
THEY'RE DOING.
A LOT OF IT THEY AREN'T ALLOWING
VIDEO ACCESS AND WE TRY TO GO
OUT THERE AND SHOW THE GREAT
WORK THEY ARE DOING DAY IN AND
DAY OUT PROTECTING THE FRONT
LINES.
THEY DON'T ENOUGH SUPPORT AND
CREDIT FOR WHAT THEY DO.
THEY DO AMAZING WORK IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE STATE.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE DRUGS, WE
TALKED ABOUT THE CRIMINALS
COMING ACROSS AND HOW THE
SITUATION WILL GET MUCH WORSE.
THE SHERIFF MENTIONED WE HAVE TO
DO IT TOGETHER TO PROTECT THIS
COUNTRY.
OF COURSE, BORDER PATROL AGENTS
NEED TO GET THE CREDIT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT LIKE THEY
NEED.
THEY AREN'T BEING ACKNOWLEDGED.
>> Harris: THEY ARE GOING TO
SEND MONEY.
>> THEY WILL SEND MONEY BUT ALL
THAT WILL DO IS PROCESS
INDIVIDUALS MORE AND GET THEM
OUT INTO THE COUNTRY FASTER.
NOT GOING TO SOLVE THE SITUATION
OR HELP THE PROBLEM.
RECENTLY TEXAS JUDGE RULED IN
FAVOR OF THE STATE OF TEXAS SO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN
REIMPLEMENT THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
POLICY.
PERFECT TIMING.
ARE THEY GOING TO DO IT?
IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
THEY HAVEN'T ACKNOWLEDGED WE
HAVE A CRISIS.
>> Harris: I WANT TO THANK YOU
BOTH.
IT IS SO IMPORTANT YOU BRING US
THE STORY FROM WHERE THEY ARE
HAPPENING.
SHERIFF, IF WE CAN'T COME
TOGETHER ON PROTECTING OUR
NATION'S SOVEREIGNTY, WE'VE GOT
REAL BIG PROBLEMS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WE CAN SOLVE THEM.
IT IS STILL THE GREATEST COUNTRY
ON THE PLANET.
GOOD TO SEE YO